نحن هنا في بلده في اقصى جنوب فرنسا هنا
محطه قطارات هي الاولى التي يعبر منها
الواصلون من ايطاليا نحو الاراضي الفرنسيه
سنرافق بعد دقائق من الان وحده خاصه من
الشرطه الفرنسيه ستصعد على متن قطار لتدقق
في هويات الركاب كل الذين لا يحملون هويات
دقيقه وصحيحه سيعاد تسليمهم الى السلطات
الايطاليه
يصل القطار نصعد اليه مع عناصر شرطه
الحدود ويشمل التدقيق في الهويات عددا
كبيرا من الركاب القادمين من فانتيميليا
الايطاليه تنجح الشرطه في توقيف مهاجر غير
شرعي من غينيا يجري اقتياده بعد ذلك الى
نقطه الحدود البريه تمهيدا لاعادته الى
ايطاليا تنظم يوميا عده عمليات من هذا
النوع والحصيله توقيف عشرات الداخلين الى
فرنسا دون اوراق شرعيه كل يوم في هذه
المنطقه التي يقصدها السياح ساحلا وجبلا
يحاول المهاجرون الالتفاف على الاجراءات
الامنيه وقلم ينجحون
جوبير قائدة الشرطه الحدوديه في هذه
المنطقه قالت للعربيه ان من بين اهداف
التشدد في المراقبه حمايه امن الفرنسيين
فرنسا تضبط حدودها كي تتاكد من انه لا
يوجد بين المهاجرين اشخاص سياتون الينا
لارتكاب اعمال مؤذيه لانه سبق وحصلت
اعتداءات فينيس ارتكب احدها شخص كان من
ضمن الذين دخلوا بطريقه غير شرعيه انتقلنا
الى الايطاليه حيث يعيش مصطفى الصومالي مع
اليكس النيجيري حياه تشبه حياه العصر
الحجري من اول نجيب من ليبيا انا من
الصومال الجنسيه هنا بالوادي ولا شيء
واشتغل ولا شيء انا بدي عيالي وعائلتي يجي
من هنا
13 سنه ما شف تقول ايطاليا انها استقبلت
العام الماضي وحده اكثر من مئه الف مهاجر
غير شرعي فيما استقبلت فرنسا بضعه الاف
فقط حسين قنيبر العربيه من منطقه الحدود
الايطاليه الفرنسيه